you talked about having a classic album
I just went viral on this podcast I was
on because I said uh that I did not
think now this goes back to the
conversation we had yeah that there's
albums that are Classics to me yeah
and I do think each one of these guys
have those for me personally but in
terms of
how like consensus hip-hop Classics and
nobody could say [__] about but it's
about chronic get Richard I try and My
Beautiful Dark Twist of fantasy good kid
math City I don't think Drake or J Cole
have a classic in that in that manner
I would disagree heavily so which one
we're going to say take care in Forest
Hills Drive Right
I will go Forest Hills Drive for sure
classic album bro I think even amongst
like the like non-negotiable for sure
that's a classic album and I agree with
that one over any Drake albums Nothing
Was the Same as a classic album
to me it is I think it's the best album
for sure man Tuscan Leather crazy
amazing
I don't know I wouldn't know honestly
hmm
so that's a classic to me but I just
don't think everyone sees it that way
who's everyone though who is everyone I
mean if you were to take
a room full of [__] a hundred
[__] who are somehow you
respect their opinion about hip-hop I
don't think everyone would agree with
that I think everyone would say get rich
or die trying is a classic yeah I don't
think you'd find a soul that'd be like
nah you're crazy you'll find four
[__] just to say it
so you think
Nothing Was the Same as a classic bro to
me it is yeah take care is a classic to
me I actually like
other J Cole [__] more than Forest Hills
Drive
um I love cold man shout out to Cole
well shout out to you this new album
you're gonna drop it's gonna be a
classic
that's something y'all man I wanna I'm
not gonna say no [__] like that that's
up to the people to decide I have no
once I put it it's like once you put it
out there on the earth bro it's just for
[__] everybody else to consume and do
what they want album coming really soon
really soon no title
two wrapper features yep
Anderson pack that's the one what state
is one of the rapper features from
Chicago
so you and Dirk no let's see we ain't
gonna I said Chicago because there's so
many dope [__] from Chicago so you in
common no so UNG herbo listen it's you
and herbo it's him and her all right so
look G herbo's on the album it's coming
soon appreciate your pulling up yes I
appreciate you having me dog